[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: Identity and
Access Management, or IAM,
in Google Cloud gives
you fine-grained control
over permissions.
But it can be complex to manage.
The IAM Policy
Troubleshooter tool
can help in investigating
issues as to why
a user has access to a resource
or doesn't have permission
to call an API.
Let's walk through how to use
the Policy Troubleshooter.
We can access Policy
Troubleshooter
using the Cloud Console,
the G Cloud command line
tool, or the REST API.
For simple queries,
using the Cloud Console
is easy and includes
a visual aid.
For more complex scenarios,
consider using the G Cloud
tool or the REST API.
In this video, we'll focus on
using Policy Troubleshooter
through the Cloud
Console and getting
the details of a project.
First off, we'll
need three parameters
to use Policy Troubleshooter--
principal, resource,
and permission.
The Principal field
is the email address
to check, which can refer to
a user or a service account.
Let's use a user account with
the email user@tse.joonix.net.
The Resource field
is the full name
of the resource we
want to test against.
The path of the full name varies
depending on the resource type.
For example, the
path for our project
is cloudresourceman
ager.googleapis.
com/projects/myproject.
You can see a full
list of resource names
in the documentation, or you can
use the autocomplete function.
The Permission field
is the permission
we're checking the user for.
Similar to the Resource
field, a list of permissions
will be presented
as we start to type.
Let's use
resourcemanager.projects.git,
which grants access to
retrieve the project.
For a complete list,
of permissions.
Check the permissions
reference documentation.
The required permission
to access a resource
may also be displayed as part
of a Permission Denied error.
You can always refer to the
specific product documentation
page for a list of
roles and permissions
that are required to
access the resources.
We can also add additional
resources and permissions
to check for the principal
by clicking on Add Additional
Pair, if desired.
We'll click on Check API
Call, and our results page
will come up.
By default, the results
will be displayed
in compact view,
which will only show
the roles that contain
the permission that we've
checked for.
We can click the toggle
to see the full view,
displaying all the roles for
our resource's IAM policy.
At the top of the
page, we can quickly
see whether the user is granted
the permission on the resource.
We can see that our
user has the permission
for resourcemanager.projects.git
in our project.
Additional details
on the policy results
are also displayed below.
The first warning, "You
do not have permission
to view all policy
bindings," may
occur if this is a resource
that's under an organization.
The user doesn't
have the permission
to view hierarchical IAM
policies on the organization
and/or the folder.
To resolve, this
the user would need
a role, such as
Security Reviewer,
at the organization level.
The second warning, "You
do not have permission
to view specific
group memberships,"
may be due to the user not
having group admin permissions.
To resolve this, a G
Suite administrator
could grant the user a role
with the groups.read permission.
The left pane contains
a list of roles
that apply to the given
resource and an icon, which
shows if our user has
a binding to that role.
We can click on the role
to highlight the specifics.
The green check next
to the owner role
indicates that this binding
grants access to our user.
The right pane displays the
raw text of each binding,
highlighting each line
for the roles and members.
Lines that don't match
our user are shown in red,
and ones that match are green.
Yellow means that the
policy troubleshooter
can't evaluate the binding.
In this case, it's
likely due to the warning
earlier about the
lack of permissions
to view group memberships.
Read more about the
Policy Troubleshooter
in the documentation.
[MUSIC PLAYING]